We use the stairs
as a place of just going up,
getting somewhere
or leaving from something
and not spending any time.
It’s not a place
that usually artworks are presented.
This is a space of transition.
I was interested in placing
work there for this reason.
How can a transitional space
become a place of pause?
So, the movement on the stairs
has a very forward
direction to it.
It's falling forward.
The choreography
goes back and forth
between this very secure place
to completely falling
down and apart.
Because it has so much to do
with this transferring
from one place to another
and how it gets articulated.
So every little thing,
even just turning the head,
becomes a movement.
You hold positions
for a long time,
that makes the physicality
also more fragile.
Your muscles start weakening
and shaking and all of that.
So, you're constantly
dealing with this—
it's not fear—but
chance of falling,
chance of everything
getting destroyed in a way.
Your body, the choreography
the aesthetics and all of that.